one thing that really did throw me off
was that hit on Travis Hunter that was
so malicious and dirty I thought that
guy should have got ejected that was
something that you hate to see in
football if you watch this the ball is
down he let go to play and the fact that
he went around his own player and hit
Travis hunter that is malicious intent
and super dirty this guy doesn't deserve
to be on no football league in college
and even the NFL we need to protect our
brothers here man life is way bigger
past football this right here is not
okay Travis Hunter you don't deserve
that brother you way bigger than this
moment the one thing I respect about
Travis he tried to get back and fight
and get back in that game and that tells
you a lot about the competitor who he is
who he wants to be and where he's going
in life and traffic you doing your thing
brother keep going everyone's supporting
you